I want to follow up and continue talking
I guess pretty directly about Sinclair
media and this has very quickly become
one of the biggest media stories of the
last week or so and when these must read
scripts provided to locally-owned to
local news stations owned by Sinclair
media when those scripts leaked this
exploded into a story that encompasses
so many different issues media
consolidation political bias blurring
the lines between news and opinion
journalism questions of what is actually
local news is it just your local anchor
that makes it local or is it the content
that would conceivably make it local and
it's getting even worse for Sinclair
because now not only have the scripts
leaked for these must read packages
internal memos have leaked and they show
Sinclair threatening their employees
that they must keep their mouth shut
about these must read scripts or there
could be consequences we actually have a
screen shot of one of these memos that
leaked and one of the key lines comes in
the third paragraph where Robert Truman
the general manager of Sinclair
Broadcast Group says I will also remind
you that giving statements to the media
or sharing negative information about
the company can have huge implications
read into that what you will and many
sinclair employees reading into it that
it's a threat and the reason that
sinclair national is doing this is that
after the existence of these
echo-chamber scripts went viral last
week some of the anchors at various
sinclair own stations started openly
criticizing the process that they have
criticizing the fact that sinclair at
the national level has complete and
total ideological control of these local
stations and sinclair is trying to quash
it now I'm not going to pretend that
this is a unique thing for Sinclair to
do when any big company has some kind of
a PR scandal it's not unexpected that a
memo would go out and employees would be
told don't talk about this stuff right
that is not the surprising part but what
is particularly ironic here what is
particularly to stir
is that this is all part of the same set
of values and agenda setting that we see
it Sinclair which is control speech at
all levels of the organization control
the speech of local news anchors by
providing them must read scripts and
packages control the speech of all
employees by telling them you can't talk
about the fact that we are being
embarrassed at the national level
because of the leak of these scripts and
it's almost a misnomer to call these
local news stations right they're
locally staffed national news stations
that's really a more accurate name and
at the bottom line how ridiculous is it
that a major press organization is
saying don't talk to press and when news
outlets start forbidding members of
their company from talking to other news
outlets you can tell that something is
very wrong here and the best analogy I
can think of is Sinclair news stations
are to the world of news what Trump
University is to academia and further
evidence of just how bad things are at
Sinclair are these internal memos the
fact that producers have started
quitting even sometimes at the risk of
having to return 40 percent of their pay
as some leaked contracts and employment
agreements have pointed out what lessons
have we learned from this I don't know
but it's really bad yeah one would hope
that some of these anchors and reporters
would continue to go public about these
must read memos or even have like the
integrity to quit their jobs but then
again the world of journalism is very
cutthroat it's very competitive and even
if some of these reporters did leave
someone would take their place anyway
yeah and some have left some producers
have left some anchors have left and of
course they'll be immediately replaced
by someone who's going to just do what
do what they're told and toe the party
line and then others of course can't
really afford it right especially with
the risk as we've seen those clauses and
some of those employment agreements
where an early departure would require
the repayment or foregoing of 40% 40% of
their salary and I don't even know if
that's yearly or for the total
of the agreement it's very very sketchy
that's for sure send me your thoughts
about what you feel are really the key
questions around the future of local
news because that's something I talk
about and cover often and this is it's a
story about local news and really about
local news not read not being so local
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on twitter at david pakman show I look
forward to hearing your thoughts today's
program is made possible in part by
shaker and spoon a monthly cocktail
subscription box that delivers the craft
cocktail experience right to your door
every month they send you the
ingredients for three completely new
original recipes enough for 12 cocktails
total that'll get you through the whole
month I got to experience the death by
gin box and I was able to make a bunch
of different cocktails for some friends
that I had visiting I could see having
the death by gin box just to have a
cocktail here and there throughout the
month if I was having company over as I
did I would love to have something like
this so I don't have to try to come up
with drinks on the fly without knowing
what on earth I'm doing which is
basically the situation that I'm in so
it's a really great thing just to have
and then you get to choose the brand of
spirit that you prefer my box being the
death by gin box meant I could go down
and pick whichever gin I wanted at my
local spirit vendor for a limited time
you can get $20 off at shaker and spoon
comm slash Pakman and if you're watching
this on YouTube I've put a link in the
description right underneath this video